what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time but
while she's trying to get rich dressed
trying to get her lunch money right i
almost forgot the name of the show but i
didn't because i got my black hoodie on
i'm here with beautiful intelligent
polina evilova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p don't forget that black fire is
now or uh that lunch my jesus i got that
friday
energy that trillionaire energy don't
forget that
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five
bitcoin is mooning block fi is moony
go get a block fi account you can earn
up to eight point six percent apy in an
interest bearing account you can buy and
sell
crypto but really just look at bitcoin
go to blockfly.com
blockfy.com if i say the third time that
means you gotta go
go to blockby.com pomp what's up
what's the first topic first topic is
uh blackrock's chief investment officer
says bitcoin could replace
gold to a larger or large extent
bang bang i've been telling y'all
because if you yell people pay attention
not true actually uh
the cio of the fixed income business at
blackrock rick reader
who is a legend a legend in fixed income
he manages just about three trillion
with a t trillionaire energy three
trillion dollars don't poke me i'm going
to say whatever i want to say
yelling that's fine i'm going to yell
i'll yell if i want to yell you can't
make me not yet
i'm a child he managed about three
trillion dollars in a fixed income
he went on cnbc today and my god the
bitcoiner
hit us with bitcoin is basically likely
to replace gold
what a legend because it's more
functional than gold than giving
somebody a
a block of gold he said that on cnbc
and the best part is if i went and said
that they'd be yelling at me like you're
crazy and all stuff
if he goes and says it everyone's like
wait what well guess what the bitcoin
has been saying this
moon bags ready put your seatbelt in
keep your arms and legs inside the
vehicle
and get ready for liftoff all right next
all right
that was my phone huffington post has a
new owner with its current parent
company verizon media reaching an
agreement to sell the site to buzzfeed
basically verizon media is also making
an investment
in buzzfeed and becoming a minority
shareholder in the digital media company
look at buzzfeed out here
acquiring media companies how do they
acquire them or is it a stock
or or did they go in the trash and go uh
pick it up
because didn't i'm pretty sure verizon
gave them the business
and also gave them cash in exchange for
uh some equity
this deal brings huffington post full
circle since buzzfeed co-founder and ceo
jonah perretti was also one of the
founders of what was originally known
as the huffington post i love this
buzzfeed has always been fascinating to
me because they basically were just like
we're just gonna be smarter than
everybody
we're just gonna figure out the
algorithms we're gonna like figure out
social media whatever
yeah but hasn't buzzfeed kind of like
disappeared from view
well they got hard-hitting political uh
coverage now yeah
all right next gaming company roblox
files ipo perspectives after 91 jump in
revenue
let me tell you about roblox the other
day i get an email in my inbox
and it's from roblox i've never been on
their site i open it and it says
your child has created a roblox account
like do you
permit them to do this and i was like
what the hell and i thought it was spam
but it wasn't it was from the company
and there was no easy way to like get my
email off of it
so unless you made an account i don't
know who's making accounts on roblox
using my email
no i didn't do that but that would be
pretty funny they have now
hit a loss lost 48 million dollars
a lot of people don't want to talk about
that revenue jumped 91 from a year ago
to 242 million
48 million on 242. well no see what you
do is you take the amount of
revenue that they have that is the
revenue isn't it oh no oh wait
yes third quarter revenue was 242
million but they lost 48 million right
that's what i mean
well that means that they burned more
than that they burnt almost 300 million
dollars almost exactly 300 million
dollars actually
290 and i'm not a mathematician okay
calculation in my head do you remember
when we were talking about tj maxx
my mom loves tj i know so does mine do
you remember one word
because it's like it's like you know
it's a cool place to shop
um they have a great like home goods
section um so tj i'm a martha stewart
guy
not even gonna touch that um so do you
remember
in earlier lunch monies when i was all
awkward and he was all annoying
we talked about how tj maxx um
kind of like refused to stuff it refused
sorry people people are texting me
bitcoin 350 candle just hit
go ahead we if it hits all-time high
while we're on okay hold on
tj maxx right now refuse my people shut
your internet so
tj maxx refused in the beginning of the
pandemic they're like we are not
gonna create a digital site where you
can shop you're gonna come in the store
and that's
a better strategy well now they're
changing course
um they they're going to launch an
e-commerce platform for its home goods
home and furniture chain in the second
half of
2021 after they resisted an
industry-wide push to ramp up online
what do you think about this oh my god
have a website let us shop
like today my friend cara just texted me
said if you shop at
dick's sporting goods right now spend a
hundred dollars you get 20
off like tj maxx could be doing that i
would rather
um carol tara stop contributing this is
like a drug addict
that you're giving drugs to stop it okay
uh wait but you also said that earlier
in the pandemic you said that they
should have a website i did yeah yeah so
you've been very
consistent on this and now you're being
proven correctly you should be the ceo
of tj maxx
can you imagine on the uh press
announcement they were like
tj maxx names new ceo pimp
they wouldn't call me pimp oh we would
don't call me pimp this has stuck for
some unknown reason and stop that
i'm spinning my phone on the table she
can't make me stop
okay do you have any thoughts no i'm
good a duh you should have a website
like uh if
it's 2020 you should probably be selling
things on the internet and if you
thought that wasn't going to be part of
your strategy
you're dumb well here's what uh the is
he the ceo yeah the ceo of tjx um
company said
not everybody wants to buy their apparel
even online they don't always want to
buy a sofa a chair an accessory item
they want to feel the fabric
dude it's 20 20. we don't need to feel
no fabric
yo you want to know what they also don't
want to send emails they want to feel
the envelope when they send a letter to
the mailbox get out of here
all right how do we okay
i'm trying to be nice to people but how
do you get a job
running a retail store and your pitch to
the board
is like yo we're not gonna have a
website
we're going to make people come into the
store we're not going to let people
press buttons on the supercomputer on
their desk
instead we're going to make them get
their lazy asses up off the couch
get in their car they're going to drive
to our store they're gonna walk around
hopefully this store doesn't smell that
there's no virus floating around
that we have what we need the pricing is
clear the cashier is not an [ __ ] like
all this stuff and then they're gonna
buy something
but they want to feel the fabric okay
it's a kid's show so i'm not going to
say it but eff the fabric
go ahead we shop for a couch in person
after i didn't have a couch for a few
months because he
bought bitcoin you want to know what
when we were shopping for a couch
bitcoin was trading at 3 200
and your boy was buying hold on i need
to so would you rather have a couch or
more bitcoin
this is me when we did not have a couch
this is me
on a mat a yoga would you rather have
that couch for two months or have more
bitcoin i guess more bitcoin
but i like to feel the fabric all right
come on let's go we have seven minutes
and then i have important things to do
an indonesian man turned an unusual bit
of property damage into a fortune when
he sold
the meteorite is that how you say that
crashed through his roof
for over one million dollars yeah he
look
um he's 33 and said he was looking
he was working outside of his home in
sumatra when the meteorite
crashed through the roof of his house
and landed outside what would you do if
a meteorite hit
our apartment he said when i lifted it
the stone was still warm and i brought
it in the house
oh my god y'all put a hot rock through
my house i'm not selling it for a
million dollars i'm holding out
there's some rich person i'm gonna tell
them it's alien rock like i'm gonna come
over the whole story
i'm gonna get it verified i'm gonna put
it in a museum like you guys are gonna
have to pay me way more than a million
dollars
but good job for this guy i mean a
million dollars he's in
because a rock fell in your house like
most people would be like damn i gotta
spend money to get my phone
i'd be like oh it's just new york yeah
yeah you have to be like oh i have to
get down and pay money to get my roof
fixed wow i'm having a bad day not this
guy
this guy's like oh [ __ ] i got a warm
rock in my house let me try to sell this
for a million dollars what happened the
other day was i was sitting outside here
we have a
lovely little balcony thing and i was
sitting and all of a sudden i was like
and i was like oh my god blue skies like
how is it
raining and i thought it was like magic
and anthony was like i think somebody's
just pouring something from the top
yeah they're washing people that are up
there are
washing their thing and the water's
coming down and she's sitting
can you imagine if a hot rock went
through the ceiling you just took the
hot rock
and you were like yo i got this rock you
want to pay me a million dollars
somebody's like yes
that dude can you imagine the banger
that guy
dro what country was he from indonesia
oh my god a million dollars in indonesia
you're a trillionaire oh he said the
money will allow his family to expand
and he plans to also donate some toward
the building of a local church
i love that where are they expanding no
they think they like have more kids yeah
i think so
okay um okay now that's one thing hold
on sorry to interrupt you for one second
but that is one thing that in the united
states
is not the first thought that would
happen people would not be like yo i got
a million dollars i'm gonna go have more
kids
i got a million dollars i'm going to
strip club that's literally what half
the people
half the people would think that okay
that's that like that's the type of
stuff that goes on in america
they're like oh my god i got a million
dollars like i'm gonna go buy a ferrari
right like it's all consumption mindset
this guy has a hot rock that falls
through his house
and then he just hits people with i now
can have more kids
and i'm going to build i think he's a
fine gentleman i love this guy we should
get him on the podcast
mr who to go do you want to tell the
people who you had the on the podcast
today
i brought a 12 year old on the podcast
yes investor yes i did he's smarter than
he's so
smart guys i listened and i was like oh
yeah okay sorry
now oh and anthony goes oh so what do
you do with 12 outside of investing do
you like go play on the playground i was
like
he's 12 he's not three nobody's playing
on the playground at 12 years old
poor kid was like i'm 32 and i still go
to the playground
okay ready ask lunch money time
ray berry how do each of you stay
positive optimistic and happy during all
this unrest in politics and an
indefinite recession coming
so i'm actually i wrote about this today
in the profile go to the
profile.subscribe.com
i think if you open your mind
up a little bit and see nuance and
complexity in the world
it gets a little bit more interesting
and you don't see things in black and
white terms so it's not either
there's a recession or there is not it's
not you know political unrest or not
you kind of you see it for what it is
and you uh learn to be happy
that's a very oh that's a very mature
view of the world
what are you gonna say go to the strip
club no
no but by the way i'm gonna get yelled
at first
for sure this is a kids show okay go on
the strip club is where they do strips
of meat
kids uh the way to stay happy
there's three things that you can do
when you wake up every morning look in
the mirror and smile for one minute
scientifically proven we'll put you in a
better mood two
go and type in to your browser positive
news
literally google positive news and
there's always positive news websites
go read those before you read the
regular news if you read three positive
headlines
every morning you are significantly more
likely at the end of the day to say you
had a good day
than to say that you had a bad day
scientifically prove it
the third thing mr scientist well i just
i looked at it
the third thing stop worrying about all
the [ __ ] in the world
who cares what's going on out there
that's what i do
all those idiots out there i'm not
smiling in the mirror for a minute
i just smile all day i'm not reading
positive headlines in the morning
because i just have positive thoughts
all the time all the idiots out there
you guys want to argue you want to fight
you want to be dummies
cool in here this is positive world in
here
that's right trillionaire energy happy
all the time
because we're all going to die if you
don't enjoy today
you don't get it back a lot of people
have never heard me talk about this but
i have no tattoos zero tattoos but
if i ever got a tattoo there's only one
thing i would ever get
uh i can't show you cause i got too many
notifications on my phone right now but
basically the background to my phone
no the background to my phone is uh a
clock
and it's 24 hours one second gone so
it's 23 hours
59 minutes and 59 seconds that's the
background it's black with
white 23-59-59 why you get
24 hours cycles use it
that's it just have fun time is the most
expensive asset you will never get
the [ __ ] that i've done for the last
12 minutes with you guys i'm not getting
back
look at uh you should read gq just
published a profile on george clooney
uh it kind of talks about how he is just
having fun because he knows that his
time is going to be up
he's just trying to take it day by day
and have fun
be happy enjoy your weekend get that
friday energy
if you need a little boost go get a red
bull and chug it
you'll be wild you'll be wired or you
can just get some iced coffee either one
works
no problem guys have a great weekend
bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends